في اثناء قالت سكرتيره مجلس الامن الروسي
نيكولايبات روشان بدنا الغربه يريد محو
روسيا من خارطه العالم وان الحرب في
اوكرانيا هي مواجهه مع الناتو بحسب تعبيره
ان روسيا بحاجه الى جيش قوي واستخبارات
لتحديد التهديدات العسكريه
كما اعتبر ان الاكتفاء الذاتي لروسيا يزعج
الغربه الذي يسعى الى تقطيع اوصال البلاد
بحسب تعبيره
كل الموارد لتحقيق السياده الاقتصاديه
الروسيه ان انسحاب الولايات المتحده من
افغانستان يعود بشكل كبير الى الحاجه الى
التركيز على اوكرانيا
تنضم الينا من موسكم مراسله هنا رانيا
جريدي لن يضيعين في هذه التصريحات
من قبل المسؤولين الروس في اضاءه على ما
يجري ايضا من واقع المعارك على الارض
الثاني على التوالي هناك تصريحات كثيره
لافته كانت صدرت ولا تزال عن سكرتير مجلس
الامن الروسي
على الوضع في اوكرانيا وعلى العلاقات
الروسيه الغربيه فيما يتعلق بالعلاقات
الروسيه الغربيه يعني شدد اليوم على ان
روسيا التي تملك كل الامكانات لتحقيق
السياده سيادتها الاقتصاديه تملك ما يكفي
من الموارد من الاراضي تملك لغه وثقافه
وعادات وتقاليد كل ذلك
يزعج الغرب حسب تعبيره ولذلك يسعى بالدرجه
الاولى الغرب لتقطيع اوصال البلاد هذا ما
يزعج الغرب حسب تعبيرهم همم فيما يتعلق
بالوضع في اوكرانيا والتطورات على الصعيد
الميداني والعالميه شدد على ضروره ان تملك
روسيا لقوات مسلحه ومتطوره لاسلحه متطوره
همم وذ في ظل التهديدات العسكريه الجديده
التي باتت تواجهها روسيا حسب تعبيره بحيث
حتى لا تسمح لخصومها حتى بالتفكير لمواجهه
روسيا عسكريه على سعيده تطورات على الارض
في اوكرانيا همم تناول اليوم باتروسوفت في
غايه الاهميه تتعلق باسباب الانسحاب
الامريكي السريع المفاجئ حسب تعبيره من
الاراضي الافغانيه اشار الى ان ذلك جاء
بالدرجه الاولى بالتركيز على همم اوكرانيا
تحدث تبادل شوف واشار لان بوفق المعطيات
التي كانت تصل الولايات المتحده همم في
تلك همم الاسنان فان الولايات المتحده همم
كانت تلقت معلومات بان ما سماه به النظام
العميل لاوكرانيا في همم في همم في
اوكرانيا العميل للولايات المتحده كان
يحرز تقدما حسب تعبيره وفي هذا الاطار همم
ايضا تصب تصريحات قبل يمكن الذي اشار انه
لو لم تنسحب الولايات المتحده من الاراضي
الافغانيه لما تمكنت تخصيص قلت تلك
الاموال التي تقوم بتخصيصها حاليا لدعم
السلطات الاوكرانيه همم فضلا عن ذلك تحدث
ايضا عن المعدات العسكريه التي تم نقلها
في تلك المرحله من الاراضي الافغانيه
اشاره الى انها تم نقل العديد من هذه
المعدات الى الدول الاوروبيه لا سيما الى
بولندا وذلك ساهم حسب تعبيره يعني بدرجه
كبيره في تسليح السلطات الاوكرانيه
لمواجهتهم روسيا
شكرا لك يا رانيا مراسلتها من موسكو